You're an idiot I guess that's the first thing you do
when you open your mouth I do
n't know if I'll erase it or not Even with this, my hair is full of hair
Please,
Beatrice
, help me,
I'll take you out of your loneliness,
Kaka.
You really don't need my strength
You're strong, smart and cute You
had enough strength in front of you to live alone
So words like help and strength didn't reach you
Arms
Even you, who are strong, smart and cute
, were afraid to live alone It was
hard,
you bought a service,
so
that person clung to existence
No one can blame
you Before rejecting Petty's feelings
, what did I eat during menopause?
I know that
you're kind, that
if someone is having a nightmare, you'll take their hand and try to reassure them.
I don't want to do it, all I can do is
cling and beg
[Music]
Beatrice
, help me